[Aplausos]
buenas tardes tengan ustedes agradezco
la invitación y la presencia para
platicar un ratito de lo que significa
para mí esta frase el poder de las
palabras en la en la cual es lo que ha
afectado en mi vida y lo que gracias a
dios me tiene hasta aquí de acuerdo a la
motivación que hemos puede lograr ahora
bien mi nombre es antonio samaranch
montemayor soy entrado al jefe
auténticos tigres el cual es el equipo
representativo de la autònoma nuevo león
como decían en los setentas para
diferenciar el equipo de fútbol soccer y
el equipo de fútbol americano decían que
era el auténtico equipo de los
estudiantes de los más de 200.000
estudiantes el otro nuevo león y por
bueno nos dedicamos prácticamente tiempo
completo al fútbol americano y hago una
pequeña introducción de qué es el fútbol
americano final del día el que agarró
una pelota de fútbol soccer aspira a
poder jugar fútbol profesional que
agarra un bate o una pelota de béisbol
aspira a jugar los yankees los as y en
lo personal el que juega fútbol
americano aspira a llegar a la nfl que
de nfl pueden fl todos lo conocemos
pero saben ustedes que son mil más bien
un millón 86 mil jugadores en
preparatoria los cuales tienen la
ilusión y el sueño de poder jugar en la
máxima liga profesional de este deporte
de ese millón 86 mil el 6.5 por ciento
juegan el siguiente nivel que es
colegial que es donde están las
universidades más prestigiadas de eeuu y
16.5 viene el 1.6 por ciento que el cual
son los que llegan a la nfl año con año
esa estadística obviamente es para gente
de eeuu un niño a eeuu nosotros los
mexicanos pues obviamente es un
porcentaje mucho mucho menor la cual han
llegado pero obviamente han llegado
pateadores o de otra posición pero es el
sueño que todos niños de niño todos
tenemos y es el sueño que obviamente
yo tuve en 1989
[Música]
cuando definitivamente yo no sabía esta
estadística
y ahí fue mi primer fracaso y la verdad
quien ha tenido fracasos yo le digo a
mis jugadores
no comete errores el que no juega el que
está en las gradas el que está afuera
ese es el oscuro que no comete ningún
error en el campo
trasladado a lo que estamos hablando
obviamente no fracasa el que no se
atreve y para eso hay que tener valor
valor de enfrentar a un jefe valor de
enfrentar un problema valor de hablarle
a la muchacha que te gusta valor de
hablarle al chavo que te gusta porque al
final del día de eso está la vida de
fracasos para que 11 nos puede ayudar a
ese dulce éxito ahora bien esa era mi
historia ser ministro y es cuando empecé
con esta ilusión y probemos en una
dinámica rápida en base a esto para
poder llegar al punto de estas dos
palabras sencillas que a mi vida le han
dado fuerza en cada una de las acciones
tengo esta frase en la cual ahorita
hacemos una dinámica pequeña literal
levantamos la mano solamente para ver
esta explicación dice antes de alcanzar
la fama ciertos productores dijeron no
nos gusta como suenan no tienen futuro
en la música yo les voy a poner tres
opciones y ahorita como cualquier
votación estudiantil les pido que me
apoyen y me levanten la mano para ver
estas historias de fracaso y éxito los
rollings stones por una parte los
beatles o the doors yo los invito a que
levante la mano quien crea que esta
experiencia fueron de los running songs
por favor si alguien cree ayúdenme no
son clases no son preguntas para ver
cómo andamos muy poquitos los beatles
obviamente
y obviamente the doors que van a ser muy
poquitos y si efectivamente en los
cuales en los sesentas tuvieron un
sinnúmero de fracasos sí sí antes de
poder dar sus primeros 42 y en 1962 con
una compañía discográfica emi records
tuvieron años y años donde le decían que
no que no que no cuando por fin en 1963
se detona lo que es la biebermanía y hoy
por hoy en base al éxito obviamente su
música sigue y sigue en el gusto de la
gente pero es fundamental esas vivencias
de fracaso para poder llegar al éxito y
obviamente el no desistir continuamos
repito son 3 a los 15 años un profesor
le dijo que de plano no conseguiría nada
en la vida nunca
sanyo ton
thomas alva edison y albert eisntein les
pido por favor que me ayuden isaac
newton a ver quien cree muy poquitos 12
ahí atrás
thomas alva edison
y hay un poquito más y realmente veréis
el cual empezó hablar a los tres años y
sus profesores suponían que tenía algún
tipo de retraso
batalló para poder tener hacer presión
al bachillerato en la prepa cuando en
1921 se puede graduar ya de un doctorado
y es cuando llega a ser premio nobel de
física dejando un sinfín de inventos y
de teorías que hoy por hoy rigen
obviamente el tema de la física y de
todos los temas científicos y ya por
último dentro de estas dinámicas decía
cada vez que entrenaba recordaba en esa
lista en el vestuario en el cual no
estaba mi nombre para los deportistas
generalmente te pone en tu listado de
quién juega quién no cuadraban no lo ves
pues te vas a tu casa vas y lo ves está
listo para jugar éste traumante yo fui
deportista y es traumante esta parte
y esta anécdota pues era de tres
deportistas
obviamente michael jordan tom brady baby
route igual le han atinado a todos ver
michael jordan quien cree que deseo
michael jordan
brading
2 carlos en tom brady muy bien y babe
ruth gran beisbolista bueno aquí sí hubo
un poquito más de paridad en las otras
dos de plano ya tiramos lo bueno en este
caso en el bachillerato dicho atleta nos
desarrollaba su físico todavía no era el
físico imponente que tuvo a lo largo de
su carrera profesional y batalló
muchísimo tuvo muchos rechazos en la
secundaria en pocos partidos tuvo acción
gracias a dios pudo pasar un
bachillerato donde no batalló mucho y ya
cuando tuvo su máximo esplendor físico
logró por fin tener un juego continuo y
a su vez ser catalogado como el mejor ni
siquiera por mucho tiempo cara michael
jordan qué
la gente más joven es la tradición de
estrella que es donde sale el y donde
nuevamente
se lleva todos los créditos en fin estos
tres estas tres diapositivas lo que
tienen en común es el fracaso es que
para llegar al éxito tuvieron que picar
piedra tuvieron que tener muchos valores
que te llevan a ser una mejor persona un
mejor grupo un mejor deportista un mejor
científico y es poder estar persistiendo
día a día buscando el éxito quizás los
mínimos comunes de ellos es que tuvieron
que controlar la frustración tuvieron
mucha resiliencia
obviamente perseverancia motivación y
dedicación que es parte fundamental no
solamente para artistas para deportistas
sino para tu vida para cualquier fracaso
que te quieras tú atrever a buscar el
éxito y que te vayas tocando con eso
definitivamente es importante ciertos
valores
esta frase yo la llevo siempre conmigo
en la cual dice que el fracaso es a
veces más fructífero que el éxito y
estoy totalmente de acuerdo porque al
final del día eso te lleva a formarte a
tener un carácter firme y que el día de
mañana
usted sepa más dulce pero nunca desistir
si tú te fijas el objetivo como horita
podemos seguir platicando creo que está
muy bien claro hasta dónde puedo llegar
ahora bien el poder de dos sencillas
palabras porque le puse así porque he
tenido varias anécdotas en mi vida que
hoy por hoy me tienen aquí más bien aquí
hablando en el tema deportivo tratando
de transmitir a mis jugadores
ganas coraje ímpetu motivación y que
creo que a mí me ayudó mucho y te ayudan
ahora que somos padres de familia del
momento en que le dices a tu hijo no
cargue ese es un hijo no podrás
no hagas eso mi hija no vas a poder
cuando estamos frenando a nuestros hijos
y en mi tiempo les platico mi anécdota
yo en 1997 en tercer año de secundaria
ahí estoy en amarillo pero tienen que
elegir una preparatoria donde estudiar
yo jugaba fútbol americano y dentro de
mi oferta académica por mi zona escolar
pues tenía ciertas preparatorias entre
ellas la 9 la 215 manero la 1 y
obviamente pues yo quería seguir
practicando fútbol americano y poder
conseguir una beca deportiva para poder
seguir mis estudios después de tener que
elegir mi carrera mi escuela obviamente
en el semestre enero-junio pues mi gran
de sami gos casi todos iban a una misma
preparatoria que era no a la 2
un coach o un entrenador mío me decía
[ __ ] 20 la 9 conmigo era coach
obviamente de ahí 20 a la 9 conmigo nos
que de aquí a 5 cuadras no vas a
batallar te voy a dar la beca hasta te
voy a dar un vale de comida y tu gente
que sigas cuando fútbol americano en
aquel tiempo lados en la potencia es
potencia hoy por hoy de las mejores
preparatorias el fútbol americano y yo
quería estar ahí cuando ya llega el
momento que tengo que sacar me fichen me
hice insistiéndome ese coach el cual yo
le agradezco y aclaró porque obviamente
basta la grabación no está en esa imagen
el coach el otra persona porque lo va a
ver y me va a reclamar uno de ellos
entonces no estaba y me dice mira vamos
a acabar pronto ventana 9 te conviene en
la 2 van muchos jugadores y no podrás no
le vas a hacer vente para acá se los
juro por mis hijos que en ese momento el
estómago se me revolvió que alguien me
dijera que no será algo que yo creo
porque he trabajado había trabajado duro
de los 4 años jugar fútbol americano el
porque él me decir que no iba a poder
acto seguido me registra en la
preparatoria 2
busque el interés de poder estar en el
equipo fútbol americano en la verdad
acudieron cerca de 150 jugadores a
buscar una oportunidad entonces mi
primer interés era estar en el equipo y
el segundo obviamente era jugar que es
la parte que todo deportista quiere que
fuer tener acción y obviamente después
de la palabra importante que me dio mi
entrenador después de acceder a la
preparatoria número 2 en la cual
quedamos campeones puede seguir
creciendo deportivamente hablando logré
participar en equipo juvenil en autónoma
de nuevo león joven ingeniería donde
tengo mi profesión de ingeniero después
tuve llamados para el representativo de
la otra mano a unión a nivel intermedia
y obviamente el sueño que también se
tiene desde niño que es jugar en un
estadio
obviamente repleto representando tu
universidad en la máxima categoría que
es liga mayor en la cual estoy orgulloso
porque era hacer fútbol americano en
primer lugar tengo estudios en segundo
lugar puede conocer países donde tuve la
fortuna de ser seleccionada nacional y
que gracias a dios hoy por hoy el fútbol
americano me ha dado mucho y todo en
base a un par de palabras
que me dieron en el orgullo el decirme
que no lo iba a lograr el decirme que no
podrás a su vez a la par me invitaron a
ser entrenador
de un par de facultades lo que es las
facultades de ingeniería civil de
formación y de mecánica y eléctrica y me
surge algo similar muy parecido donde un
amigo mío al cual también invitaron me
llevamos a civil éramos estudiantes de
mecánica vamos a civil hay menos coaches
aquí en firme mira todos los coches que
están son muy experimentados son muy
buenos vamos lo mejor para allá aquí no
vas a crecer aquí no vamos a crecer no
vamos a poder mejoramos avanzar allá y
literal en ese momento al recibir la
misma frase el mismo mensaje dije no yo
me quedo aquí aquí me quedé en mi
escuela que admiro a los coaches que en
ese tiempo el cosmic servants el cual
hace algunos años falleció el cual fue
un gran mentor para mí me enseñó
muchísimo y creo que la edición que tomé
fue la correcta
al final del día pasé de ser asistente
a cercos de posición a ser coordinador y
en el 2006 se retira el coach mike me da
la oportunidad de estar al frente del
equipo de fútbol americano y después de
resultados importantes durante 89 años
puede llegar y escalar en el tema
deportivo para después recibir la
invitación del equipo auténticos tigres
en su categoría intermedia y obviamente
hace tres años 2016 recibir la
invitación para poder estar en frente
del programa auténticos tigres donde
definitivamente los resultados se van en
base al esfuerzo el esfuerzo lo mío el
esfuerzo de todos el esfuerzo desde el
compañero de trabajo el esfuerzo desde
el compañero que está en la clase el
esfuerzo de todos pero el fracaso está
latente el fracaso está para todos y si
no agarramos la motivación que en mi
caso era ese par de palabras yo estoy
seguro que para cada uno de ustedes
podemos buscar una motivación para poder
que lograr objetivos a final de cuentas
el rechazo iba a estar el rechazo lo
vamos a tener siempre pero la
resiliencia la dedicación las ganas el
objetivo firme
y que tú te ayudes buscando una
motivación intrínseca es lo que nos va a
ayudar a poder avanzar día a día
y bien en estos tres años este el cuarto
hemos durado un par de campeonatos 16 y
el 18 el 17 estuvimos a una jugada de
poder ser campeones y hoy por hoy en
pleno 2019 literal hace tres semanas que
metieron la diapositiva estamos pasando
un momento muy difícil el equipo estamos
batallando iniciamos muy mal el año
teníamos muchos años de no perder dos
juegos en una temporada y cuando la
estaba haciendo ya teníamos los juegos
perdidos no sabía que iba a poner la
diapositiva dije para esa fecha de la
ponencia van cuatro juegos yo espero y a
ganar para esa fecha pero es una época
difícil que estoy seguro que con el
trabajo de cada uno de mis jugadores de
mis coaches con la motivación que cada
uno expulse y agarre nos tiene que ir
mejor y al final del día a lo mejor
ahorita no me dicen no podrás ganar
a lo mejor nos llegan esas palabras a mí
pero yo busco mi motivación y después de
ver tweets porque estoy en redes
sociales tratando de agarrar la
motivación de mis jugadores y ver hacia
cuánto que los auténticos tigres no iban
0 2 3 semanas
tigres cuatro partidos en fila perdidos
ya es un fracaso qué bueno esto me ayuda
final día para mí en motivación y es lo
que le transmite a mis jugadores
tigres versos blancas por el morbo de
ver si tigres quede eliminado
por último lo dije hace varias semanas
son los peores tigres de los últimos 15
años
todos tenemos piedras que tenemos que
saltar todos tenemos problemas en la
vida ningún problema es sencillo hoy
tratamos un tema laboral hace años mis
problemas eran diferentes tenemos
familia hay problemas con los hijos hay
problemas con la esposa y problemas con
todos lados pero el cómo los afrontemos
y el cómo nos motivemos es lo que creo
que al día de hoy puedo decir que para
mí es esa motivación la más importante
el que me agarre ciertas palabras y
poder yo mismo luchar por el objetivo
final y ya para terminar
en la búsqueda de ese objetivo y lo
importante del éxito laboral familiar
como ustedes lo quieran ver y en ese
camino difícil para llegar a la cima les
pongo una frase la cual la trate de
modificar un poco para todos nosotros en
la cual yo la llevo siempre quizás no se
lo digo a la persona cuando me lo dice
pero si lo pongo en mis frases así que
cuando te digan no podrás hacerlo
responde todo corazón muchas gracias
arriesgó su atención espero haya sido de
su agrado la presentación y muchas
gracias por su atención
gracias
[Aplausos]